what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alba John Humphrey over so we I just got
done doing a live stream Q&A over on
patreon helping us prepare for the
Shimogamo now movie trivia there's this
animated short film called
in a heartbeat that a lot of people have
been requesting we check out a lot of
people's former most requested videos
and this whole week I wanted a way to
get permission from them to make sure
that it would be ok check it out and
back to us on Twitter and Facebook and
said it's all ok to check it out so here
we are see what all the hype is about
Ringling College oh smart he's gonna
make me cry
[Music]
I'm here the crush on him like with his
heart playing with his heart
my other man to be my heart next you'll
get a man the tortoise has gravitated
toward my wallet
love it part 1 but one
[Music]
Oh
oh don't break his heart
ah feeling that's so sad and yet in this
part of my face
oh poor dude this body
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ah glowing all that was awesome it was
wonderful I really knew it one thing man
that was really amazing that was
beautiful I love you know the literal
interpretation of your heart being
gravitated towards someone ready to give
it to someone in the fear of rejection
in your heart getting broken and torn
apart and embarrassed and the end of a
guy came back once a nice if you
compliment me it is that nice visual
metaphor just like the heart wants what
it wants
yes and then yeah matter how much she
was fighting it yeah trying to resist
the fact that his heart wanted him so
back and it just didn't deny it and then
in the end I love that moment when he
came it was back with his other like you
know that the phrase the metaphors of
you completely you're my other half yeah
what happens there ah yeah and I mean
goes out saying the animation is superb
in here the animation is ridiculously
good well there's an animation school
project it is impressive to look at I
think and I love the mannerisms ya know
all the mannerisms of the characters the
way they react in the little movement to
me you know not being an animation
expert but I know some animators I've
seen some things and this looks pretty
polished you know pretty great that was
on par with like those Pixar animated
short films that play before Pixar films
yeah I kept feeling like it could be
that maybe that it's like the subject
matter I'm sure is controversial in some
of its own weight as me having two boys
right now not about that light as much
as you know we're definitely not those
people who are against that whatsoever
I was very touching I got a little misty
I was watching that action what I feel
like this is a nice good bridger because
it is again it's that visual metaphor of
just like everybody can relate to that
yearning feeling that your heart has yes
we're fortunately be part to live in a
part of America that is you know okay
with gay people for the most part yeah
we're not worried are part of America
that are not okay with it is just nice
to see a short film about these gate
literally a little love story and the
context is kind of lesson in the none of
the back of your mind but it's there
you know because especially when the
kids are looking at them like you start
to wonder about the context in that
moment yeah are they judging them yeah
for them being two guys or is this just
an awkward funny way happen exactly as
much as I appreciate films or stories
that you know push the agenda of how
people at attacking gay people is wrong
I like that this short film didn't
really go for that approach at all it
was just a sweet short film about two
people who were drawn to each other yeah
it's really sweet and innocent in a way
and they have just a little love story
yeah and that it really did warm kind of
touch my heart out is beautiful do you
like that element is just sort of like a
night to me is this sort of like a nice
surprise yeah it's not like in-your-face
you know I know sometimes people
complain about DeLeo I'll be billed gb2
story yeah they did it in a really nice
visual I really like these when they're
when they're visual there's no dialogue
and stuff like that like they're just
people that's it this is that simple
little and I like that approach it just
lets just treat them like they're just
people we don't have to push any message
it's like that's what I like about it
yeah I didn't feel they were pushing any
messages there yeah this is actually to
me a really good route and just
accepting this is just a normal thing
that goes on this is just a normal
relatable thing that goes on with people
because we can all relate to that
feeling it doesn't matter who's on the
opposite side of it we all know the
feeling where your hearts like come on
dude you're like I don't know what yeah
I'm going to get rejected over to be a
better so right now this is people are
around their machine yeah awkward no
yeah especially in the school years yeah
and that definitely happened early
crushes and stuff thanks for requesting
make sure requesting disguiser thank you
guy really and thank you for the people
who made in a heartbeat that David and
Esteban
Bravo SM on Bravo's only got back to me
on Twitter thank you guys so much for
letting us watch this yeah research it
because that was that that is very
effective that's one of those short film
who's never going to forget yeah this is
a school project so I'm hoping that you
guys are able to force in the animation
career your names on a feature so yeah
the graduation of a success of your
video going so freakin viral Matic
eduation especially that baka was fine
yeah well guys thanks for tuning in you
can subscribe to the real rejects make
sure to subscribe to these guys for any
upcoming feature animation short end if
this is your first time watching it just
in the little box we have here please it
go watch it in full screen format go
click on the actual video link check us
out on patreon if you like to get John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram click
notification bell a bunch of social be
everything's in the description box and
I need to keep lugging by